You might be thinking, we're talking about love again?
And your students might look at it and think, we're talking about love again?
Well, we're going to keep talking about love.
Because love is so important. I mean, Paul said it in 1 Corinthians, right?
If we have all this stuff, if we're this amazing person, we can do all these
amazing things, but we don't have love, then it's all for nothing.
So we want to make sure that we talk about love now see at this
point you and your students have walked through an incredible amount of
information in fact they're so much more intelligent and hopefully
confident in their conviction for what we as Christians believe it's exciting to
think when I look back at this book about all the stuff that they've studied and
that you guys have gone through, it's really, really exciting to think back to even
just where we started from.
But also, it's really easy after you've been through all of this to have so
much knowledge crammed into your head.
And you might have, I hope you have students that are really excited to share what
has now been crammed in their head and hopefully in ways that their hearts have been
changing and incredibly impacted by what you guys have studied over the last several
months. That instead of sharing that sometimes with
love, sometimes we get caught up in trying to be right.
Sometimes we get caught up in trying to get notches in our spiritual belt.
Sometimes we get caught up in trying just to win the argument and be able to beat
down on somebody else's beliefs or somebody else's faith.
And that's not how we want to do it.
So we wanted to make sure that we took time out to communicate the idea
of communicating your faith to others in love and in
humility. And that can be really difficult to do.
It can be difficult to train someone to sit back and actually take the time to
listen and take the time to be interested in what somebody else says, to take the
time to really and be just like Jesus.
So that's really what this lesson is all about.
And we want your students, just like we put inside the introduction activity, is
what does it look like? What does it feel like at a time when they actually
experienced love? We want them to kind of go back into that moment so they
understand what they felt like so that they understand how others ought to feel like
when they express love of some kind to another person.
So for this week I'm going to take you a little bit off script maybe for next week
as well but I want you to work on something.
I want you to work on role playing.
It's not necessarily what's inside here but after kind of walking with you guys
through this process, I sat back and thought, I really feel like you guys should do
some good quality role-playing. Now that might be between two students.
That might be between you and another student or another adult leader and a student.
But the idea here is as a teachable moment, you want to show students
what it looks like to engage in a conversation with another person in love,
but you also want to show students what it looks like to engage another person in
conversation without love. They need to see both.
And even if you have two students and one of them is displaying something that's
good, maybe one of them is displaying something that's not so good, don't ridicule
them, but use this as a teaching moment so that they can see it.
Because some students are just bent toward arguing.
I've had students over the years that that no matter what you do, no matter how you
say it, they're trying to be loving but they just want to argue and they just want
to win. And other students don't want to argue at all and they just want to be
agreeable. And based on different students' personalities, they need to see a couple
of different things. And so involve as many students as you can, get them role
-playing a little bit, and use those things as teachable moments so your students
can get a feel for what that looks like and feels like before they ever go out
into any kind of conversation.
But they're going to go out into conversation.
I hope they go out and have conversations, but remind them they're going
to mess it up and that's okay. They're going to come back and go, oh, I should have
said this and oh, I should have said this and oh, I came off wrong and oh, I said
this wrong or I didn't think of this or I forgot that or that's okay.
The fact that they remember those things afterward will continue to build their
confidence and they'll continue to get better and better and better just like
anything else this is a skill that has to be developed but encourage them to
continue to use it encourage them and find ways as a group to get out together
so you can do things together and encourage each other and spur one another on but
make sure your students see exactly what love ought to look like and as real
of a scenario as you can get okay so small group small group time
is going to be interesting because what you would you have an opportunity this time
to do is talk with students on how they can love in different ways maybe in ways
that they've never thought of depending on the dynamic of the particular group they
might not be able to think of love in particular terms it'd be another student can
think of so students need each other to bounce ideas is back and forth so they can
kind of sort of understand how it all will work in their particular situation.
So how one student perceives loving on another person is going to be far different
than maybe another student. So use your small group time as a way to kind of open up
that conversation to really explore on all the different ways that students can
connect with other people in a way that Jesus would.
Okay, so last thing.
We talk about love because love is what builds relationships.
Please remember that it is so important to build relationships.
Make sure your students understand that this is not about getting conversions.
This is about building relationships.
Jesus said to his disciples that it's by your love and by the way you treat one
another that they'll know who that you are my disciples, that they'll know who I am.
The way in which we love other people is how some people are only ever going to
see Jesus.
Don't focus on the conversions, focus on the relationships, and focus on the ways in
which we can love others.